>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D. C.
>> Paolo Bacigalupi is
an award winning writer
of science fiction and fantasy.
His debut novel the "Windup
Girl" shows a vision of humanity
after being nearly wiped
out by genetic engineering.
It is chalked full of weird
foods and strange beasts.
It's one of the top ten
fiction books of 2009 by Time.
Won the Hugo, Nebula, and John
W. Campbell awards in 2010.
"Ship Breaker," his
novel published in 2010,
was award the Michael L. Printz
award for best young adult novel.
It was nominated for
the National Book Award
for young people's literature.
His recent novel the
"Drowned Cities" is a finalist
for the LA Times Book Prize of 2012.
Paolo Bacigalupi has written
fiction for the magazine of "Fantasy
and Science Fiction" as a
model of science fiction
and the "Environmental
Journal High County News."
In an article last
summer on wired.com,
"How Cyberpunks Saved Science
Fiction" Paolo Bacigalupi wrote
that science fiction was stuck in
a complacent groove by the 1980s.
A lazyboy recliner
experience of the future.
Competent men of science did
competent things aerospace was the
coolest tech.
And politics revolved around
the conflicts of nation states.
Paolo Bacigalupi looks to inspire
and lead a new breed of writers
who looked to touch on raw
issues that interest us all.
In that vein, "Zombie Baseball
Beatdown" bashes you on the head
with your very own funny bone.
Explores raw themes if food
safety, racism, and immigration.
No. Trying to understand who this
gentleman is he'll certainly tell
his own story well enough shortly.
But I did a little looking.
And I came up across a site
that said that it stems from --
it was a very old name Bacigalupi
that goes back to a
Italian mythology.
Meaning something along the
lines of a kiss of a wolf.
Although couldn't really
tell if that was true or not.
There was alternate meaning of it
that said some person
of dubious integrity.
So I'll leave that to
all of you to decide.
But please, join me and welcoming
one of the great emerging writers
in this genre Paolo Bacigalupi
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you [applause].
I've got a tail with me here so.
Wow, hi, everybody.
It's great to see you.
It's also terrifying to see you.
Whenever I stand up in
front of people and talk,
I have this almost immediate
fight or flee reaction.
And so my first urge just as I
was standing down there was maybe
if I can just go hide behind here
I'd throw up for a little while.
I'll be fine.
But, yeah, thank you very much.
So as you know now my
name is Paolo Bacigalupi.
I do write science fiction.
And I do watch people
sort of immediately sort
of flinch whenever I say that.
I've sort of got this sort
of theory about which version
of literature is most despised.
Is it romance?
Is it science fiction?
Is it children's literature?
And whichever one it is that
you're sitting next to somebody
and they say, oh, what do you write?
You say I write science fiction.
And they go, oh, I don't read that.
You say, well, that's nice.
Or you say, oh, well,
I write for children.
Oh, that's easy writing, right?
I wish it was easy writing.
But so -- but I actually write
science fiction for children,
for young adults, and for adults.
And I'm really interested in
speaking to different age groups
because I feel like I
have different stories.
And i have different ideas
I want to share with people.
And it's also the most
satisfying thing for me as writer
because it feels like I get
to stretch different literary
muscles each time I write
for a different age range.
So, yeah, so that's kind
of a little bit about me.
I did actually want to ask you
guys a question because a lot
of the inspiration for
"Zombie Baseball Beatdown" --
I still love saying that title.
Came from the sort of
very specific realization.
And I just want to ask you all
how many of you have been forced
to read a book that you didn't like?
How many of you have been forced to
finish a book that you didn't like?
Right. Okay.
How many of you have been forced to
finish a video game you didn't like?
We got one [laughter].
How many of you have been forced
to finish a TV show
that you didn't like?
All the way through to the end?
Yeah, a few.
Okay. So it's interesting to me
that like when you look at media
and we look at something like
books and then we look at something
like video games, it's
interesting to me that we've decided
to turn books into a
medium that's also a misery.
And I'm not quite sure
why we do that.
We seem to have some
idea that books,
even if we're suffering,
it must be good for us.
It must be worthwhile.
It must be important.
In fact, maybe even
the more we suffer,
the more you know grimy
oatmeal we're forced to shove
down our throats, the
healthier we'll be
if we read these good
books that are good for us.
For me, actually my
experience with this was
when my stepmother decided I would
not be allowed to read another book
until I read John Steinbeck's
the "Red Pony."
And this book for those of
you who haven't read it,
I'd say don't [brief laughter].
For me as a kid in middle
school reading this book
that was good literature --
my experience of it wasn't that
it was sad or anything like that.
It was that it was dead boring.
It was a slog.
It was a fight to get
through every page.
The words blurred on the page as I
just waited for the page to turn.
And I hated that so much.
And it was interesting because at
the same time I was actually reading
quite a lot.
But I was reading science fiction.
I was reading stores
about rocket ships.
I was reading fantasy
stories about dragons.
I was reading about great
quest with great swords.
And there's, you know, something in
here where I was experiencing joy
in reading in another space
that my stepmother called trash.
And then she wanted to hand me
something that she's called good.
And that was where I was
supposed to reside with reading.
If she had had entire control
over my reading experiences,
I would not have become a reader.
And one of the things that
I've noticed in our schooling
and in the way we treat books
oftentimes is that we know
which books are good for us.
And we know which books
are bad for us.
And never the twain shall meet.
And that's a fascinating sort
of value set that we apply
to this specific media more than
any other media that I've seen.
And when I go and --
so all of that said,
then my wife is school teacher.
And she teaches children who are
generally in the range of 4th, 5th,
and 6th grade, that age group.
So -- and she has some
kids who hate reading.
And so one day she said to a couple
of these kids, she says, well,
what do you want to read about?
Like, let's start with that.
And all the kids sort of
look at her and say zombies.
And sure enough if you go out
and you look at what's available
for a 4th grader or a 5th grader
or a 6th grader about zombies,
there's a little bit available
in books about zombies.
But it's all really cute zombies.
They're all the, you know, the
zombies that just need a hug.
They're the zombies that you
can defeat with hot sauce.
Now, at the same time
that this is going
on my 9-year-old son is playing an
iPod game called "The Earn to Die."
Where you level up by getting bigger
and bigger vehicles so you can drive
over more and more zombies.
And you drive over them
and the zombies splatter
and blood goes everywhere.
And, you know, he's driving faster.
And he's laughing the whole sometime
while he's playing this little iPod
game and driving over zombies.
And here we got for his age
range in books; you have stories
about zombies that need a hug.
But the iPods giving him what he
really wants, which is he wants
to drive over a bunch of zombies.
In that moment, I think you have
to look at where your reader is.
And if you're going to have
somebody become a reader,
you're going to connect
with their desires.
You're going to connect
with the things they love.
You're going to reach
out, and you're going
to meet them where they want to be.
You're not going to tell them, no,
reading is the "Red
Pony" here try this out.
You're going to say,
you want zombies,
I'll give you some zombies, kid.
And that's where I wanted
to be with this book.
I think that the thing for me
that started me as a reader
and made me eventually a writer was
that I found that books were joy.
That books were a pleasure.
They were excitement.
They were, you know,
they were getting
to watch characters do
death defying things.
With "Zombie Baseball Beatdown"
I wanted to write a story
where kids got to fight
off the zombie apocalypse.
Where a bunch of kids
with their baseball bats
and their teamwork skills were
going to fight the zombie hoard.
And they were going to
save their small town.
And I love that feeling.
That as soon as I started thinking
about that story I started
getting chills I was
so excited about writing it.
So I wanted to meet kids
right where they are,
which is they want
to be entertained.
They want to be engaged.
And they want to have a
joyful experience in books.
They don't hate reading, they hate
the crummy stories we give them
to read.
And so I'm going to read just
a small section from this.
And then I'm going to
talk a little bit more
about also what else I'm
thinking about writing
and reading in literature.
And then after that, assuming
that I don't get a buzz here,
I'd like to take questions.
If you guys have any questions.
So this scene happens
some of the kids --
when I started thinking
about the zombie apocalypse
and creating a zombie apocalypse,
one of the questions that came
up was where was does the
zombie apocalypse come from?
And for me, the perfect
location for a zombie apocalypse
to start spreading from was
the local meat packing plant.
You know, meat handling is a
very, very interesting thing:
Where our meat comes from;
how our meat gets raised;
how our meat gets slaughtered.
It's interesting stuff.
And there's all sorts of ripe,
you know, opportunities for abuse
in our meat packing system.
So this was where I decided to
start my zombie apocalypse from.
And in this scene, the kids have
snuck into a meat packing plant
to try to find where the source
of the infection is coming from.
It's here, Miguel said, standing
in front of some steel doors.
What is? He didn't answer.
Just swung the doors open.
We stood in a cavernous
factory room tangled
with conveyers and equipment.
Meat hooks dangled
from chains overhead.
Conveyer belts went every which way.
And massive boxy machines that might
have been grinders or other things,
but I couldn't tell,
were everywhere.
The place was so big you couldn't
even see the far side of it.
We eased into the space.
It was scary with all the
chains and hooks hanging
down from their conveyers.
What are we looking for, Joe asked?
Something that looks zombie, I said.
Anything. The concrete floors all
glistened with water and blood.
And everything gleaned.
It was chilly, and it had
the scent of a meat locker.
It was like smelling life gone cold.
Our breath steamed in front of us.
What about the cows, Joe asked?
Where did they go?
Miguel waved to the far side
of the huge factory floor.
A bunch of them are in the
next room over in a huge pen.
The cows get herded up one by one
up a ramp that leads into here.
Suddenly there was a rattling sound.
Hi. We ducked behind
the conveyer lines.
Footsteps echoed along with
voices calling out to one another.
I thought they were all
supposed to be gone, I whispered.
Another shift, Joe asked?
No. It's only supposed to be
cleaning crews, Miguel said.
The guy I talked to
said they were going
to be cleaning the whole plant.
So the nightshift wasn't
going to run.
Just cleaning.
Lights buzzed and flickered on.
Workers in white, full body
jump suits streamed in.
Joe found a spot under
some of the machinery.
Hide here.
We just barely squeezed under.
Don't let your feet stick
out, Miguel whispered.
They'll see us for sure.
It was tight but we all fit.
From our hiding place, we watched
as more and more workers came in.
Who do those guys remind
you of, I asked?
Clean up squad, Joe said grimly.
Yeah, none of these are
regular workers, Miguel said.
Not with those clothes covering
their whole bodies like that.
And they don't have aprons
like my uncle and aunt used.
These have got to be some
other kind of Milrow people.
The conveyer line started up.
A door rattled, and suddenly
we could hear cows screaming.
More workers came in with huge
knives and chain saw like machines.
They fired them up as
the lines started moving.
The first cow appeared.
It had a huge hole in its head.
But that didn't seem to
bother the cow at all.
A bunch of hooks snagged it
and swept it off the
ground as it struggled.
Moo, the workers went after
it with knives and saws.
The cow tried to bite
them, but they were fast.
Cutting and chopping
peeling away the skin.
The head came off.
The belly opened up.
The guts went down the drain.
The cow's head fell to the floor.
Moo it said.
It's hooked body was still jerking
around even without its head.
A zombie cow for sure, Joe said.
As if we needed him to tell us.
The cow was still alive even
though it was completely dead.
One of the workers got
kicked by the dead cow.
But he got right up and
chopped the carcass in half.
Then water sprayed it and the
next worker whacked off the legs.
The carcass whizzed along
carried by the hooks with more
and more workers slicing
cuts of meat
from the body even
as it kept wiggling.
The cow -- look at the rain --
the zombie cow became smaller
and smaller and less
and less like a cow
as each worker took a whack at it.
Pieces and parts were slashed
and sliced away and dropped
onto conveyer belts that whisked
the meat this way and that way
through the processing plant.
Heading for who knew where.
Another cow entered
the production line.
And the clean up squad
went up to that too.
Moo, slice, hack, chop [chain
saw sounds] went the chain saws.
Another cow whacked
into little red pieces.
More of the line was gearing.
It was crazy loud in the
factory now like we were
in the belly of a clanging monster.
Ground up meat oozed
out of delivery tubes.
And newly cut steaks whipped
down the conveyer lines
shrink wrapped in plastic.
More and more cows were
being herded into the doors.
And every single one
of them was mooing even
after it was chopped up and dead.
The cow heads that
had been discarded lay
in a huge pile snapping
at one another.
And at any workers
who walked past them.
Pound after pound of
red hamburger poured
out of the machines around us.
Globs of beef that dropped
on to Styrofoam plates.
And then went through shrink
wrapping machines so that they came
out on the other side
looking shiny and fresh
with Milrow meat stickers
on the plastic.
Labels sped past us.
Farmers Feast 100 percent
all natural ground beef.
Forest Glen Acres pure ground beef.
High Plains Ranches USDA
natural ground beef.
Milrow Meats top quality beef
from our family ranches
to your family table.
Joe had his cell phone out, and he
was snapping pictures looking sick.
I think I'm a vegetarian, he said.
Miguel gave him an annoyed glance.
Where did you think
your meat came from?
You think it just [inaudible]
into the night supermarket
like night crawler?
I had to agree with Joe though.
It was brutal and nasty.
None of the workers
seemed to be worried
about what they were doing at all.
They were just being
super efficient.
Even if it hadn't been zombie cow
heads lying on the ground mooing
and rolling their eyes
and snapping their teeth,
the whole set up didn't
feel good to watch.
I mean, I went out to
a farm with my dad once
where we bought a sheep for mutton.
And we saw the farmer
kill the sheep.
He stuck his knife in
the sheep's throat.
And we watched him kill it.
And it was uncomfortable
because you could see
that something was dying
so you could eat it.
But killing a sheep up close
and personal wasn't like this.
The sheep bled and got chopped up.
And dad and I ate it, sure.
But this Milrow factory
was something else.
Cow after cow coming into the
plant and getting ripped to pieces.
High speed chopping,
ripping, tearing, shrinking.
I wondered what kind of people
could create a factory like this.
All for tearing animals
apart as fast as possible.
It scared me.
They're turning all the zombie
cows into food for people, I said.
I can't believe it.
They're insane.
It was all zombie cows.
Not a single real cow
in the whole bunch.
So this is what ground zero for
the zombie apocalypse looks like.
Joe snapped more pictures.
I sort of thought it would be a
military science lab somewhere.
We've got to stop this, I said.
We can't let them do this.
There's a stop button
on the line, Joe said.
Miguel whacked him upside the head.
Not just now, idiot.
We got to report it.
We got to make sure
this all gets stopped.
We need something they can't
sweep under the table, I said.
Something the cops can't ignore.
Real zombie proof, Joe murmured.
Something you just couldn't
make up, Miguel said.
Moo, moaned the cow heads lying
in a giant pile at the beginning
of the meat packing line.
Moo, we all looked at each other.
A mooing zombie cow head, yeah,
that would probably do the trick.
[ Applause ]
All right so I loved
writing this book.
I had far too much
fun doing this book.
No one of the things that I
also kind of wanted to talk
about was the idea that we know
what's good for us in literature.
And we know what's bad
for us in literature.
We know what's trashy.
And we know what's healthy for our
kids to read or for us to read.
And we separate those things
out in really interesting ways.
And I'm not sure that I believe
that that's actually the right way
to think about storytelling.
I have this feeling that
it's possible for us
to have our cake and eat it too.
That we can have all
the joys of running
around in the pop culture
space of zombies.
But we can also talk about other
things that are extremely serious.
The opportunity to talk about
where does our meat come from?
How do we treat it?
What do we eat?
Who's in charge of it?
How does it get regulated?
Who protects our food?
All of those questions
are also in this book.
And it's one of the things that's a
huge pleasure for me is to be able
to say I'm going to
tell you a fun story
about kids beating back the zombie
hoard with their baseball bats.
Oh, by the way, let's think about
how food works in our country too,
because that's interesting.
And I think you can have
both of those things.
And it can all be a
fun, thrilling package.
And there's none of this,
like, oh, it sucks to read it.
This is actually going to
be fun all the way through.
I get to learn.
I get to have joy both
at the same time.
And that's where I think that
sort of literature needs to be.
And that's where unabashedly we know
that almost all other media wants
to be, is they want
to sort of spread joy.
They want people to be
engaged and entertained.
Video games movies, TV
shows, are all trying
to engage and entertain first.
Everything else comes second.
And I think that books have made a
mistake somewhere along the line.
And definitely our teaching
establishment has made a mistake,
you know, the way we do our testing,
everything to say no
good for you first.
Oh, if you have fun, well,
we'll try to accept that.
But please, you know,
don't have too much fun.
And I really sort of want to
bring those two ideas together.
It's like, yeah, we
can think about things.
We have been thoughts.
Big themes.
And also big, big zombie battles.
So -- thank you.
[ Applause ]
So if anybody has any questions
I'd be happy to answer questions.
I'm happy to talk about
almost anything.
So feel free and fire away.
I guess there are microphones
on either side here so.
[inaudible comment]
>> Hi, as an educator of teachers,
I agree with a lot of
what you're saying.
But I would also ask the question
of how many people have been forced
to read a book that they
turned out that they loved it?
And that could be the book that
you're talking about, as well as any
of the other literature
in the world.
So I think that that's an
important question to ask as well.
>> It's an interesting
question is --
the question is sort of how
many people have been forced
to read a book and then found
that they did love it later?
And I think that that's possible.
Certainly I had a teacher
in high school who forced me
to read Shakespeare for a semester.
And eventually I did
come to love Shakespeare.
I was taught to eat the
right kind of food I suppose.
I think though that especially when
we talk about our classic literature
that we forget how our classic
literature knew that it needed
to earn it's keep in its time.
Shakespeare didn't
sit down to say, oh,
I'm going to force
you to enjoy this.
He was actually writing
exactly for his popular culture.
And so I feel like there's a --
we've decided that because
it's hard therefore it's good.
As opposed to, because it's
enjoyable therefore it's good.
Because it's engaging
therefore it's good.
I feel like we've somehow managed
to sort of worship our past enough
that we've forgotten that our
present is actually what most
writers -- the reason why
writers are classics now is
because they were deeply
embedded in their present moment.
And writing very, very specifically
for their present readers.
And we sort of managed to separate
that within our educational system.
I'm not saying that
it can't be done.
I'm not saying that we can't
be taught to enjoy new things.
But especially at younger ages,
I think that it's a horrible,
horrible thing to do somebody is to
say, no, no, keep going, keep going,
keep going and suffering.
It's like I think you
start with the sweets.
You assume that -- for me
at least, I think about this
as being the question of, like,
you assume that if I can get kids
to start reading and enjoying
reading and loving reading,
this is not going to be
the last book they read.
The idea is it's the
first book they read.
And that gets them on a journey that
goes all kinds of different places.
But if I start out with something
that's horrible and boring
and difficult and not engaging
and not relevant to me,
then it will be the last book.
And that's sad.
And then they -- and the iPods
and everything else
will take them instead.
I do think that there's
a point in our lives --
and for me I didn't
actually read any, you know,
major what we would call
like quality literature
until after I was out of college.
Until then I read science
fiction entirely.
That was what I read, and
that was what I truly loved.
And then there was a
point when suddenly I was,
like, oh, this is interesting.
You know, Hemingway,
oh, fascinating.
Oh, "Virginia Wolf."
Oh, fascinating whatever
those things were.
I was finally ready for that.
If I had stopped reading
at an earlier stage though,
I would have never even had a
chance to pick up those later books.
So it's kind of what I think about.
Other questions [brief applause].
>> [inaudible] what exactly
made the cows zombies?
>> What exactly makes
the cows zombies?
Well, I don't do spoilers so,
like, you'd have to read the book.
But you can get it
at the library too.
I'm not just trying to sell them.
The things that they
start to suspect.
I'll tell you this much.
That they start to suspect that
there might be something in the food
that the cows are eating.
And they start to think also that
the way that the cows are being fed
and raised in the feedlots
at the meat packing plant
which are very, very dirty.
Feedlots tend to be very, very
dirty infected places already.
And so when the kids go out
and investigate in the feedlots
and they see the conditions there.
And they see some of the drugs that
are getting used on the animals
to make them grow bigger
they start thinking
that there might be something
connected to that so.
>> Hi. I'm mom of three sons and
an elementary school librarian.
So I want to say thanks
for writing what they love.
It's a huge challenge
to get boys to read.
And we're listening to you with
[inaudible] and all the stuff
that they love, so that's fantastic.
And also for including --
you're making them think.
They're enjoying it, but
then they're going to think
and make some really
good evaluations as well.
So my next question is going to
be what the kids always ask me
when they find a book that
they fall in love with,
which they probably
will, which ones next?
How many are in the series?
And how long do I have to wait?
>> [brief laughter]
And this is actually --
this is a difficult
one for me to answer
because normally I don't
normally do series.
I normally will write a book,
and there's a set of ideas I want
to open up inside of that book.
And it's oftentimes it
becomes a stand alone.
In my young adult work,
the "Ship Breaker"
and the "Drown Cities" I manage
to still keep the books
in the same world.
But I found that I
couldn't write a series.
I needed to explore different ideas.
So with "Ship Breaker" it was
really about family and about sort
of a boy learning to sort of
find his way into a better life.
And with the "Drown
Cities" it was really all
about politics and
fighting and wars.
And how we either negotiate or
don't negotiate to get along.
And with different themes,
very, very different themes.
I do really want to go
back into the space though.
And I keep having this
vision of these kids.
I have more ideas.
So, yes [inaudible] --
>> Why did you use zombie cows
instead of regular zombies?
>> Why did I use zombie cows
Actually I used both.
So there's zombie cows.
And then later on when the
people eat the zombie cows,
then they become real zombies.
And so there's a whole
bunch of scenes of the kids
with their baseball bats having
to fight real human zombies also.
So both of those things
are in there.
>> Hi. My question is just
you talked a little bit
about where you got the idea
for "Zombie Baseball Beatdown."
What was your inspiration for
"Ship Breaker" and "Drown Cities"?
>> Okay. What was my inspiration
for "Ship Breaker" and
the "Drown Cities"?
Originally my -- the
biggest inspiration
for "Ship Breaker" actually
came from the idea that I wanted
to write about broken futures.
I really am interested in
sort of the bad futures
that our present day
decision-making might create.
But I also wanted to write about
something that was inspiring.
And so I was really interested
in writing about [inaudible]
like high technology,
sustainable technologies.
And I really wanted to introduce
the idea of a new age of wind
that would say we can have a global
economy that's based on wind.
We used to in the 1800s.
We did all the way up until
coal and steamships took over.
And so I really wanted to sort
of think about new technologies
that were inspiring to me.
That I wanted to make them seem
inspiring to the new readers.
Because I kind of wanted
to inspire people to go out
and build new high
technology [inaudible].
Kind of like the things that
are in the America's cup.
Or things like that but bigger.
And, yeah, so that was part of it.
There's almost always a lot
of different inspirations.
For the "Drown Cities" actually
my big inspiration was our current
political problems.
Our inability to talk
across political lines.
across differences.
And asking the question really if
this goes on where do we end up.
There was a line in a very early
draft of the "Drown Cities"
that I ended up throwing
away everything else except
for this one line.
And these characters are
sailing pass the "Drown Cities."
And the "Drown Cities" are
a terrible war torn area.
And this kid asks he says,
well, how did we get this way?
How did this place
turn out this way?
And the captain of
the ship says, well,
a nation this powerful doesn't
just fall apart by accident.
Somebody has to tear it apart.
And he says the demigods
whipped up the people.
And the people bit
on their own tails.
And they chewed and they chewed
until there was nothing left
but the snapping of teeth.
And that was important to me.
The idea that we can
actually chew ourselves up.
And I wanted to write
about that kind of a world.
And say, hey, maybe
we shouldn't do this.
Maybe we do need to find some ways
to talk across our differences.
So that was the inspiration
for that.
So thank you, yeah.
Yeah.
>> For the concept
of the infected cows,
did you get that idea
from Mad Cow Disease?
>> Yes, actually.
Did I get the idea
from Mad Cow Disease?
Yeah, I'm really interested in
actually Mad Cow Disease, BSE.
Creutzfeldtz-Jakob Disease, yes.
But also from other kinds of meat.
Food safety outbreaks like E.coli.
You hear a lot of about
E.coli in hamburgers.
You here about salmonella sometimes.
You also hear about this
and other kinds of parts
of our industrial food system like.
You know, I remember
peanuts got infected I think
with salmonella a while back.
You know it's, like,
oh, this is interesting.
And you find out almost all of
your peanut butter is coming
from two factories so that's it.
Like, you know, it's all these
different brands are all affected
by this one peanut
factory or whatever.
And so that was all of
those kinds of food --
sort of food disasters that
we have were real interesting.
Yeah.
>> Hi. And just want to say that
we share the same hated book.
The "Red Pony" was the first book
I ever read that I did not like.
So I feel your pain on that.
I'm a middle school
teacher librarian.
And I absolutely loved "Ship
Breaker" and "Drown Cities."
I like speculation with
interconnected issues
and how it gives the
reader a sense of potency.
An idea that they actually
can steer things.
But one thing that I
think is not really talked
about a lot is underlying
diversity issues linking all these
things together.
Those books tend to
have, in my opinion,
really notable representation
of different cultures
and backgrounds -- people with
disabilities, people of color,
people of different ages.
So I'm assuming that you, you
know, did that sort of on purpose
or least were cognizant of that.
So I wondered if you could
just talk a little bit
about why you think diversity is
important in young adult literature.
>> Yeah. So the question of
diversity and the idea of lots
of different kids being
able to find themselves
in books is really,
really important to me.
And you see this sort
of joy that a kid has
when they find somebody
who's like them in stories.
And they can connect to that.
And you do notice that in a lot
of our literature and in a lot
of our movies, a lot of our TV
shows there's an overwhelming sort
of middle American whiteness to it.
That doesn't really represent
what we are as America today.
It doesn't really represent
the globe.
And it's a missed opportunity.
For myself, you know, and especially
it is actually absolutely deliberate
that I trying to make more and
more diverse cast of characters.
All engaged in doing
interesting and amazing things.
You know in "Zombie Baseball
Beatdown" actually it was --
the main character is named
Rabi Chatterjee-Jones.
And he's half Indian.
And that's because my
son is half Indian.
And one of the things that
I noticed was that he --
when he's able to read a book or
see a story or see a TV show --
I remember the first time
he saw some Disney TV show.
He said, dad, I saw this show.
And there's an Indian in it.
And he's smart like me.
I was like -- and you're
just heartbroken
because you realize how scarce that
is for him that joy and that appeal.
And so you sort of want to open your
arms really wide and bring in lots
of different people to
experience great stories.
So thank you.
Thank you.
And I think that's everything.
So I'm over time now.
So they're going to
grab a hook with me.
So thank you so much.
[ Applause ]